الصحفي اشرف ابو عمره اهلا اشرف لو تجمل
لنا ابرز تطورات الوضع الميداني صباح
اليوم في
غزه نعم التطورات حقيقه في المحافظه
الوسطى وبالتحديد في منطقه شرق مخيم
المغازي وشرق منطقه المصدر التي شهدت خلال
الساعات الماضيه تطورات دراماتيكيه مع
اعلان الجيش الاسرائيلي قبل قليل مقتل هذا
العدد الكبير من الجنود الاسرائيليين هذه
المنطقه شهدت خلال الساعات الماضيه غارات
اسرائيليه مكثفه من الطا الحربيه الاف 16
بالاضافه ايضا للمدفعيه الاسرائليه ولم
تكد ايضا سماء هذه المنطقه خاليه من
القنابل الاضاءه التي استمرت على مدار
الدقيقه خلال الوقت الماضي وهذا ما يشير
بان هناك
عمليات حدثت في هذه المنطقه وفعلا نحن من
حيث نقف هنا في مستشفى شهداء الاقصى
والمنطقه ليس بالبعيد كثيرا عنا هنا
شاهدنا وسمعنا اصوات انفجارات واشتباكات
عنيفه خلال الساعات الماضيه وهذا ما اكد
الروايه التي خرجت قبل قليل عبر وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه عن حدثا استثنائيا في
هذه المنطقه هناك عمليات تفجير لمباني
سكنيه حدثت قبيل المغرب بالامس وتم رصدها
ومشاهدتها والسنه الدخان التي تصاعدت من
تلك المنطقه اي بالتحديد من منطقه شرق
المصدر وايضا شرق منطقه مخيم المغازي
بالاضافه الى شرق مدينه دير البلح
بالاضافه الى ذلك عمليات نعم طبعا ونحن
نغطي هذا الحدث مع مقتل 21 ضابطا وجنديا
في وسط قطاع غزه نعلم ان الاتصالات اصلا
مقطوعه في القطاع وان الغزيين مشغول
مشغولون بمعاناتهم الانسانيه ولكن ما
اصداء ما حدث هناك في
غزه حقيقه منذ ساعه الصباح والمواطنون
ياتوا هنا للصحفيين ويتم مساءلتهم او حتى
الاستفسار عن هذا الحدث الذي منذ مساء
الامس والاخبار بدات تتناقل هذا الخبر
الاصداء بشكل الكبير اخذت مجالا واسعا لدى
الناس هنا والنازحين الكل مهتم بهذا الخبر
وعندما نتحدث عن الخبر ونتحدث ايضا عن
قربه من المكان الذي نتواجد به في هذه
الاوقات بالاضافه الى ذلك نعم بالفعل
الاتصالات مقطوعه عن كل القطاع بالاضافه
الى ان هذا الانقطاع ياتي با ايضا الجوانب
السلبيه هنا على مستشفى شهداء الاقصى وعلى
الطواقم الطبيه وسيارات الاسعاف التي باتت
لا تتحرك كثيرا في الساعات الماضيه لنقل
المصابين والشهداء ونتحدث عن منطقه غرب
خانيونس حيث جاء اعداد كبيره من المواطنين
النازحين الذين خرجوا من المناطق الغربيه
جراء كثافه النار وكثافه القصف الاسرائيلي
وصلوا هنا الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى
وتحدثوا بان هناك اعداد كبيره من
المواطنين الجرحى ما زالوا على الارض
وعندما نتحدث وسالنا لماذا جئتم هنا الى
مستشفى شهداء الاقصه قالوا بان هناك
القوات الاسرائيليه تستهدف المناطق
الغربيه اي منطقه المواص بالقذائف الم
فعيه فاضطروا لاخذ هؤلاء المصابين هنا الى
مستشفى شهداء الاقصى وهذا ما ايضا اعاق
عمل تحرك سيارات الاسعاف باتجاه هذه
المناطق التي تشهد عمليات عسكريه وعمليات
قصف مستمره فالاتصالات اشرف عفوا لو
تحدثنا اكثر عن هذه المنطقه التي شهدت
تفجير هذين المبنيين والذي ادى الى مقتل
21 جنديا وضابطا اسرائيليا ما الذي نعرفه
عن هذه
المنطقه نعم نتحدث عن محورين اساسيين ل
العمليات العسكريه التي كانت مساء الامس
محور شرق منطقه المصدر وهي تقع الى الشرق
من مدينه دير البلح بالاضافه الى شرق مخيم
المغاز القوات الاسرائيليه قبل عده ايام
كانت قد دخلت الى هذا المحور اي محور شرق
المصدر ومنطقه شرق مخيم المغازي انسحبت
قبل تقريبا 72 ساعه قبل ثلاث ايام من هذا
المحور القوات الاسرائيليه كانت تناور في
هذه المنطقه ما بين الحين وال اخر تقوم
بالتقدم باتجاه الغرب الان وانا معكم على
الهواء مباشره يسمع انفجارات كبيره ايضا
في هذه المنطقه الان وانا معكم على الهواء
هناك انفجار كبير جدا في هذه المنطقه التي
تشهد عمليات عسكريه قبيل المغرب بالضبط
حدث انفجار كبير وهو شهدت السنه الدخان
تتصاعد من المكان هذا الانفجار ليس
كالعاده يعني يتم يعني تنفيذ غارات جويه
ولكن بعد الانفجار بقليل تبين بهذه بان
هذا الفج هو ناجم عن عمليه تفجير وتفخيخ
لمنازل لمواطنين في شرق منطقه المصدر وتلى
هذا الانفجار ايضا احزمه ناريه هائله اي
هناك طائرات اف 16 تدخلت مباشره بعد
التفجير حسب ما شاهدنا ورصدنا نحن حين كنا
متواجدين بالقرب من المنطقه شاهدنا طائرات
حربيه اسرائيليه اف 16 نفذت احزمه ناريه
هائله وقويه جدا صحب هذه الغارات الجويه
ايضا عمليات واصوات اشتباكات قويه وضاره
جدا كانت في هذا المحور اي محور شرق
المصدر وشرق منطقه المغازي حينها بدات
ايضا الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
الاباتشي تحلق على ارتفاعات منخفضه وبشكل
ايضا لافت وكثير في هذه المنطقه باتت تطلق
النار في كل مكان هناك شهد ايضا عدد من
هذه الطائرات تهبط في نفس الموقع الذي تم
فيه عمليات التفجير ولحتى صباح هذا اليوم
هذه العمليه لم تنتهي ولم تتوقف بل زادت
وتيرتها قبيل الفجر عندما كثفت المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه من اطلاق قذائفها باتجاه
منازل المواطنين في شرق المصدر وشرق
المغازي وشرق مدينه دير البلح هل شاهدتم
هل تمكنتم من
مشاهده جانب من عمليات محاولات انقاذ
وانتشال هؤلاء الجنود والضباط
الاسرائيليين في هذه
المنطقه ن نعم حقيقه هذا ما شهد وبشكل جلي
الطائرات المروحيه الاسرائيليه الاباتشي
التي هي ما دائما تتدخل في مثل مثل هذه
الحالات والان ايضا سلسله انفجارات جديده
تحدث في نفس المحور وفي نفس المنطقه
الطائرات المروحيه شاركت بعمليات انزال
وهبوط في تلك المنطقه بالاضافه ايضا
للمشاركه بعمليات اطلاق نار من الرشاشات
الثقيله من قبل هذه الطائرات المروحيه
الاباتشي التي لم تفارق اجواء المنطقه
بخصوص ايضا القصف المدفعي والتغطيه
المدفعيه بالقذائف في نفس المنطقه وفي
محيط المنطقه التي شهدت هذه العمليه لم
تتوقف تماما والطائرات الف 16 ما بين
الحين والاخر تقوم بتنفيذ ايضا عمليات قصف
جوي مركزه على شرق منطقه المصدر وايضا
سلسله الانفجارات وانا اتحدث معكم الان
على الهواء مباشره تسمع في نفس المنطقه في
شرق منطقه المصدر وهنا الاشاره بان منطقه
المصدر هي قريه وحي ليس بالكبير يقع الى
الشرق من هنا من حيث مستشفى شهداء الاقصى
لا يبعد سوى تقريبا ال 800 متر الى كيلو
متر مربع حيث تشهد هذه المنطقه عمليات قصف
مركزه عمليات ايضا قصف مدفعي من قبل
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه بالاضافه ايضا
للمسيرات الاسرائيليه الكوات كابتر وايضا
الطائرات المروحيه الاباتشي شكرا لك
الصحفي اشرف ابو عمره كنت معنا من دير
البلح